[Music]
Parisian Couture could influence how
thousands of ordinary women dream and
live but fashion needs a new
leader now F your
head
[Applause]
M I keep looking for the great collect
ction to Rise From the Ashes of the
[Music]
war what do you desire design the most
beautiful women's cloth that ever
existed ruin French and I'm coming back
to save
it for those of us who lived through the
chaos of
War creation was
Survivor The Legend of Coco Chanel
if people only
you have to come and arrest me can be
very treacherous oh
yes are you happy with the revolution
you
started there is the truth my mind is
but there is always another truth that
lives behind it your sister she's not
safe creation cannot stop the bullet but
creation is our way forward
our choices matter I
am use my
legs use my
head use my your house will be
magnificent you think Jo is
speci real talents is turning your life
into something
[Music]
bigger
people need to fear dream they need to
live again we can create a new world for
[Music]
them